in 1976 two soviet cosmonauts were sent
on a mission to the salyut 5 space
station the last dedicated military
space station in the soviet space
program the commander and flight
engineer boarded the soyuz 21 beginning
a mission that was meant to last 66 days
but after just 49 days the mission ended
abruptly the cosmonauts were reporting
something dangerous aboard the space
station a noxious chemical smell
ground control scrambled to get them
back to earth
soon after a replacement crew boarded
the station with breathing equipment
with concerns there was a fluid leak
filling the rooms with toxic gas
but after a thorough inspection they
found no odor no gas no technical
problems at all
subsequent reports of psychological
problems in the soyuz crew led nasa to
conclude the odor was probably a
hallucination
brought on by the long hours exhaustion
and the harsh effects of the utterly
alien environment of space on the human
body
the human body is an amazing machine but
it's simply not built for a life in
outer space
in the last 6 million years we've
evolved to thrive in earth's
environments from the frigid cold
terrain near the poles to the sweltering
regions along the equator but not in the
weightless abyss of the final frontier
nevertheless we continue to seek worlds
beyond our own
nasa and other space agencies have plans
to send astronauts farther than we've
ever traveled well beyond earth's
atmosphere and even the moon crude
missions to mars which are intended to
take place in the 2030s will involve
long duration flights and months or
years-long stays on this far off planet
this will have a profound effect on the
human body which has already shown a
wide range of health issues during stays
on the international space station
which begs the question how will it be
possible for the human body to injure
months years or one day entire lifetimes
in the unnatural inhospitable
environment of outer space
though we don't often consciously think
about it every moment of every day an
invisible force glues us to the surface
of the earth
our skeletons our muscles our hearts
pumping blood through our veins are all
perfectly adapted to exist and the
specific amount of downward force
created by earth's gravity
but as soon as our body leaves our home
planet this all completely changes
in outer space microgravity feels like
total weightlessness
and on mars gravity is one-third of
earth's
and with less force acting on the human
body things start to get weird
in the microgravity of space astronauts
bones are no longer being used to
support their weight or movements and
they lose one to two percent of their
bone mineral density each month
for a one-way trip to mars which will
take about 9 months this could amount to
as much as 18
calcium from their degrading bones
floods the bloodstream and can even lead
to kidney stones
on earth we also lose bone density
during our lives but under normal
conditions it's replaced as fast as it's
lost
but in space that's not the case it's
largely due to the bones not having to
support any weight
the drop in bone density is known as
disuse osteoporosis
and leaves bone weak and prone to
fracture
if left unchecked astronauts who've
spent long periods in space may not even
be able to walk when they return to
earth
in our lives on earth gravity also pulls
down our bodily fluids
without it astronauts blood and other
fluids are pushed upwards towards the
head causing it to swell
this increased intracranial pressure can
lead to vision problems
to try to correct these issues
astronauts can wear compression cuffs to
keep their fluids in their lower
extremities and use resistance
treadmills to build back muscle and bone
mass
but for longer missions this might not
be enough
and this is why scientists are now
working to not simply combat the lack of
gravity but to recreate it
artificial gravity can in theory be made
using centrifugal forces
this type of machine is commonly found
in science labs but you may have
experienced the same effect while
driving fast around a curve or on a
carnival ride
when traveling in a circular path at
high speeds in an enclosed vehicle a
centripetal force is created by the
outer wall that holds you inside
but to you it feels like you're being
pushed against the wall
that push is called the centrifugal
force and it can be used as an
equivalent for gravity
there are a few ways that this can be
implemented in a spacecraft the first is
by making the whole thing rotate
there have been some different designs
created by nasa engineers such as these
stick-like designs that rotate like a
baton
but rotating an entire spacecraft is
tricky for a number of reasons
maintenance of a rotating craft can be
difficult and guidance and control can
be even more difficult
another option is rotating just one part
of the spacecraft but again this comes
with some technical issues and has even
more moving parts than rotating the
whole vehicle
so scientists are thinking even smaller
an on-board centrifuge that can fit one
astronaut at a time
they are currently investigating the
time the astronauts would need to spend
inside to keep their bodies functioning
properly in these tests the effects of
microgravity are simulated using a bed
rest model the test subjects lay with
their bodies tilted negative six degrees
head down for a miserable two months
straight this unloads the bones and
muscles and causes the bodily fluids to
flow towards the head
each day some participants spend 30
minutes in a centrifuge either over
several sessions or all at once
the scientists then compare a number of
physiological outcomes between the two
artificial gravity groups and the
control group
so far they found that 30 minutes of
artificial gravity provided some
improvements in muscle function and
balance
but other negative effects such as
vision loss were unaffected
these results suggest that a longer
duration in the centrifuge will be
needed to successfully counter these
health issues
but even if the body is functioning
correctly it does you no good if the
mind is not
[Music]
our minds are fragile things and our
mental health can be a challenge to take
care of even in the best of
circumstances
many of us got a taste of the effect of
isolation during the worst of the covid
lockdowns and that was in the comfort of
our own homes with the entire netflix
and steam catalogs at our disposal
living in outer space stuck in a small
artificial environment far from home
with the same group of people with
little to no privacy for long periods
would be enough to obliterate anyone's
mental well-being
then add to that the inherent danger of
the environment and the difficulty of
performing a high-pressure job and it
could easily be a recipe for disaster
these circumstances can and do lead to
cognitive impairment depression
psychosomatic illness and even
psychiatric disorders
hallucinations like those experienced by
the soyuz crew are not uncommon
other astronauts have hallucinated
orange clouds flashes of light and
angelic-looking figures
another critical aspect for the mental
health of astronauts during long-term
space travel is group dynamics several
missions have been interrupted due to
interpersonal conflict between crew
members and with mission control
in fact the crew on sky lab 4 turned off
communication with nasa for a whole day
after arguing with mission control
because of these issues space agencies
like nasa have been studying people in
isolated environments for many years
these studies include evaluating
astronauts in space as well as
participants in confinement in analog
facilities here on earth
stations in antarctica provide one such
test bed
antarctica's climate terrain temperature
and isolation resemble that of outer
space
the landscape is uniform and boring the
sensory deprivation is real and so is
the danger
crews there cannot be rescued quickly
and everyone there is stuck with the
same few people just like astronauts in
outer space
and under these conditions something
important about team dynamics has been
revealed
to have a successful team you need not
simply impeccable leadership or flawless
decision making
what you need is a clown
humor it turns out is critical for
diffusing tense situations in antarctica
and by that logic in outer space too
joking around is also essential for
coping with boredom brought on by
prolonged periods of isolation
scientists are now working to build a
computer model that can help select the
best crew based on personality traits
like this
one day soon nasa will be able to add
the information of prospective crew
members to the algorithm play various
simulations and receive some predictions
about which combinations of people are
more or less likely to work well
together as a team
on board the ships researchers have also
improved lighting to help align
astronauts circadian rhythm in order to
improve sleep and alertness
activities such as learning a new
language or skill
tending to a space garden or even being
immersed in a vr world will help avoid
depression and boost morale but the most
insidious danger of outer space is one
you can't see nor hear nor even feel
you wouldn't even know it was killing
you until it was far too late
outer space's silent killer is radiation
a form of energy that travels as rays
electromagnetic waves and or particles
we experience it every day when we step
outside into the sun turn on the lights
microwave food or use our cell phones
but while these and other more hazardous
forms of radiation that we experience
here on earth can cause adverse health
effects the radiation in space is much
worse
that's because there are two types of
radiation non-ionizing and ionizing
non-ionizing radiation is less energetic
and can easily be shielded out of our
environment
some sources of this on earth are power
lines tvs cell phones and microwaves
the light from the sun that reaches the
earth is largely composed of
non-ionizing radiation since the
ionizing far ultraviolet rays have been
filtered out by the gases in the
atmosphere particularly oxygen
and this is a very good thing for us
earthlings
ionizing radiation is much more
dangerous
in outer space ionizing radiation comes
from three sources
particles that are trapped in earth's
magnetic field called radiation belt
particles particles usually protons that
are shot into space during solar flares
known as solar particle events and
galactic cosmic rays which are composed
of the nuclei of atoms that have had
their surrounding electrons stripped
away and are traveling at nearly the
speed of light
ionizing radiation has enough energy to
alter the substance it travels through
it does this by removing electrons from
the atoms in the material which ionizes
them
this can greatly damage the human body
and even break apart our dna placing
astronauts at significant risk for
radiation sickness increased lifetime
risk for cancer central nervous system
effects and degenerative diseases
the amount of risk depends on the dose
of radiation that they're exposed to
which is measured in millisieverts
here on earth we typically experience a
small dose
for instance an average person in the
u.s is exposed to about 6.2
millisieverts each year mostly from
radon and medical imaging
however in space solar particle events
and annual galactic cosmic ray exposure
produces a much higher radiation dose
one study measured this to be about 3
500 millisieverts for a large solar
particle event and up to 700
millisieverts each year for galactic
cosmic rays
if astronauts are to spend any length of
time in space they need high levels of
protection
space agencies like nasa have safety
precautions in place to limit astronauts
exposure to radiation
currently these include things like
shielding radiation monitoring exposure
caps and operational procedures like
delaying a spacewalk until after a solar
particle event with current precautions
astronauts experience 50 to 120
millisieverts during a six-month stay on
the international space station with a
single day resulting in about 0.7
millisieverts
while this is significantly higher than
what we experience on earth it lets even
the most vulnerable astronaut a 35 year
old woman spend
857 days aboard the iss before reaching
nasa's radiation exposure cap which in
her case is 600 millisieverts
nasa uses radiation exposure caps to
determine how long astronauts can stay
in space
they calculate the cap based on a risk
estimate the limit is the amount of
total exposure that would give an
astronaut a three percent higher chance
of dying of cancer in the rest of their
life
but that cap isn't equal for all
astronauts
women are more vulnerable because they
are more susceptible to the cancers that
radiation can cause due to the nature of
their reproductive organs and younger
people are more vulnerable because they
have more time to develop cancer in
their lives
but more distant missions to mars which
will require up to a thousand days in
space will expose astronauts to much
higher doses of ionizing radiation
potentially far surpassing the current
radiation caps which range from 600 to
1117
millisieverts depending on the
astronauts age and gender
this could increase their lifetime risk
of dying from cancer well beyond the
three percent limit set by the cap to
over 10 percent
the reason for the high levels of
radiation exposure even inside a
well-shielded spacecraft is due to the
nature of galactic cosmic rays
while solar particle events can be more
easily shielded galactic cosmic rays are
more penetrating and move at such high
speeds that typical shielding materials
can't slow them down
researchers discovered that to
completely block them the whole of the
spacecraft would have to be outrageously
thick
so thick that the additional weight and
fuel requirements would make the trip
impossible
this is why scientists are looking into
other protection methods for these trips
one option are wearable vests that
protect the most vulnerable areas like
the lungs and reproductive organs
these vests are currently under
development and tests of their
effectiveness against radiation are
planned for the upcoming artemis moon
mission
however the companies developing the
vests are focusing on solar particle
events so it's unclear how well they'll
shield astronauts from the more
penetrating galactic cosmic rays another
shielding technology being explored are
electronic surfaces that actively
deflect radiation these are known as
active shielding methods and involve the
generation of an electromagnetic field
similar to that on earth
but these have some drawbacks as well
since they require a massive amount of
energy their power comes from
superconducting magnets which are heavy
and require a cooling method
but shielding may not be the only way to
protect astronauts from radiation
scientists are now looking to the field
of medicine to counteract its effects
one radical idea is to genetically
engineer astronauts to make their cells
more resilient to radiation this could
be done by turning on or off certain
genes or by combining their dna with
that of a more radiation resilient
animal like tardigrades
while this may sound like something from
a science fiction movie scientists have
already expressed a tardigrade protein
in human cells grown in a petri dish
leading to a reduction in the amount of
radiation-induced damage
this particular protein called damage
suppressor prevents the animal's dna
from breaking when exposed to high dose
radiation
the human cells containing the protein
had 40 percent less dna damage than
cells without it
while we're still decades away from
genetically engineered astronauts
extreme solutions like this may be
necessary to push the human body beyond
the limits of its evolution so it's able
to handle environments well beyond those
found on earth
and long-term space missions are closer
than you might think the artemis mission
plans to put the first astronauts on the
moon since 1972
with the goal of building a new space
station in lunar orbit and eventually a
habitable moon base on the lunar surface
the goal is to travel to the moon and
stay there
so we can learn how to build a
sustainable colony on other worlds
boots might be on the ground of the moon
again in as little as three years
and it will push the human body to its
limits
building the lunar orbiter and ground
stations will require hours of
spacewalks
an activity that comes with enormous
risk
risks so high that on a previous
construction spacewalk on the iss
an astronaut almost drowned in his
spacesuit
to learn more about how the crew saved
him and about how nasa plans to keep
astronauts safe during this new era of
space travel you should watch secrets of
the universe to the moon and beyond on
curiosity stream it's one episode of a
brand new eight-part special event on
curiositystream that details how space
agencies are seeking answers to some of
the universe's biggest questions
this is one of many incredible series on
curiosity stream alone curiositystream
is a fantastic educational streaming
platform
but now curiositystream has partnered
with us to offer an even better package
by signing up to curiositystream you now
also get a subscription to nebula
nebula is a streaming platform made by
me and several other educational youtube
content creators
it's a place where we can upload our
videos ad free and a place where we can
experiment with new original content
we have so much exclusive content
planned for nebula this year like a real
science series on human evolution and
real engineering's new ongoing series
the battle of britain
so for just 1479 you get access to both
curiosity stream and nebula for the
entire year that's 26 off the usual
price with two great streaming services
for the price of one
plus signing up is the best way you can
support this channel
with your support we've been able to
hire more animators more writers and
start producing some seriously high
quality films
so go to curiositystream.com
real science to get in on this
incredible deal
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video about the first creation
of living robots
or watch real engineering's latest video
about the insane engineering of the
concorde the incredible supersonic
passenger airplane
you